so yeah I mean sorry I'm so I don't talk
about this stuff really except for like
therapy so I don't know
I'm gonna like not go into like that
mode
just a video
that that kind of chronicled all of the
cancellations oh my God yeah are we
gonna show up on some sort of list
having you on
whatever was interesting was that like
it was uh you know they said in in some
cases people will like uh you know
build careers become famous and then do
something like super offensive to people
but in this case of Shane Dawson he uh
that is not what happened that that like
Shane Dawson was super offensive the
whole time is actually like what he
became famous for so then it's like
uh it's just an interesting Dynamic
where uh you know you were just a wild
outrageously offensive guy and
everything was great until
people just got upset about it after the
fact
uh yeah sorry
um yeah no it was
it was a lot I mean listen like I
I'm not one of those people that's mad
that I got canceled I mean maybe in the
beginning I was you know yeah because I
those videos were from a long time ago
and a lot of this stuff was from a long
time ago and I hadn't done anything like
that in years but I mean I'm also kind
of glad it all happened because
I made me face a lot of things and
realize uh yeah a lot of things right
um so uh what has been um what's been
going on recently do you remember maybe
when when we got together like all those
years ago I uh I think I called up my
niece on the phone or or maybe we made a
video and sent it to my niece but my
niece was just such a rabid Shane Dawson
fan and I texted her yesterday I said I
said are you still like a fan of machine
Dawson yeah like uh I said oh because
we're gonna record a podcast with them
tomorrow and she goes WTF oh my God
that's great and uh she said from what I
gather he's doing very well since uh he
got in trouble with the popular media
her take on it seems to be that
that uh that you're they get the your
cancellation so to speak was with like
the mainstream media and that you know
under you know and and kind of your
world not sort of under that radar that
everything's cool
yeah I mean I
I think it was like when I started doing
YouTube
the people that were watching were you
know
I think the the types of people that
were watching my stuff changed in like
2018 2019 and I started doing things
about makeup and I think it opened up to
and not to make excuses I think I
started doing YouTube videos for kind of
like [__] up weird Outcast people and
then the more mainstream YouTube got the
more I was doing documentaries on like
or documentaries people don't like me
when I call them that but I was doing
videos about people that were more
mainstream so it was a lot of like yeah
and then they were really surprised by
all the old videos obviously
so yeah I mean sorry I'm so I don't talk
about this stuff really except for like
therapy so I don't know haven't you
talked about this stuff before though or
just not publicly I don't think I've
talked about it like
yeah not really like I'll touch on
things in in podcasts a little bit but
then I kind of stop because I I don't
wanna it's hard it's hard to talk about
stuff because if you talk about it
people think you're trying to be a
victim if you if you say about certain
things they think you're manipulating or
you're trying to change the narrative or
all this [__] so I just don't talk about
anything I mean the fact that you're
nervous about it is pretty authentic I
think and like
it's better than having like you know
being a prepared because you could tell
when you start to talk about it you stop
talking about it which means like
there's shame around it and like the
neurons are just looping back to the
same
spot and I think talking about it helps
kind of connect new like neural Pathways
to where you're not like so you know
flight or fright
uh with it and it just gets easier and
easier
but if you're not comfortable talking
about anything you know we don't have to
talk about anything at all I think
there's something to what you said too
that uh you know when you say the fact
the chain is nervous about it there's
something authentic about that you know
like uh if you're if you're really
comfortable like oh yeah let's let's
talk about you know like that no problem
there then um it feels like you know
there's no gravity to it and you know
like uh yeah there's certainly trauma
around it because like I I can when
you're breathing out like that like I'll
do that in therapy and like my therapist
is like dude
your brain doesn't know the difference
between like you know you running your
rep because like when that kind of stuff
happens like you're operating off your
Reptilian Brain and so it's like your
body doesn't know the difference whether
you're running from a dinosaur or like
somebody's just asking you a question
because like it hasn't been processed
so I mean I think it's good to to talk
about it and I mean I think the worst
has already happened right and nobody's
going to find out anything you haven't
lied about anything so like you know
saying [__] I think is okay but I think
the fact that you are nervous about it
is a good thing because it's authentic
oh thank you I mean that exactly what
you said sorry I've like cottonmouth
exactly what you said
is what my therapist said too which is
like
yeah I got into a place where
I was in fight or flight mode 24 hours a
day
or like
I mean not not as much anymore I don't
want to seem like I'm like [__]
like I'm just showing up to do a podcast
like that's not yours that's good
but you know like the last two years
after I got canceled and I was like I'm
done not making any videos ever again
I'm done I went through you know not to
get to you know whatever but it was
really bad and then we moved we moved to
Colorado that's where my husband's
family is and I'm really close to them
and I just wanted to get away for a bit
and also we found this house out there
that was unexpected so we moved out
there
and I had the best year of my whole life
like 2020 was really bad and 2021 was
like
I wasn't on my phone I wasn't on the
internet
um anyway yeah it was the best year ever
and then
and then around the end of 2021 I
started thinking like I wanna I do want
to make stuff again and
and like you said it's like
I'm obviously ashamed of a lot of the
old videos and the old sketches and
stuff but like you said I didn't
it's not like a secret thing I didn't
hurt anyone I mean I guess I heard
feelings but I didn't physically hurt
anyone I didn't rape anyone I didn't
like I didn't do anything to where I
should be in hiding
it took me a long time to get to that
place
to to believe that but
you know that I shouldn't be in hiding
or something but but when we were coming
out here and you're like okay I'm doing
a podcast where were you like oh [__] I
don't want them to ask me this oh I mean
what was the shame or fear there about
doing a podcast like because I know
there's maybe something specific that
you thought about that you didn't want
to go near
I mean it sounds
whatever but I
my biggest fear and why I say no to a
lot of stuff like this I thought I'm
getting asked a lot but I say no a lot
because I know the reaction is going to
be possibly negative for you guys so for
me I'm like okay
I love you I'm so grateful that you came
on my show all those years ago like that
was [__] insane like I still have
people asking me about that like my
brother's obsessed with you so
I wanted to say yes but I know you're
gonna get [__] and you're going to get
comments people are going to be like
can't believe you had him on and all
this stuff and then I'm not going to
read it but I don't want that to like
[__] up your [__] and I don't want
you to regret it and yeah so it's like a
lot of like feeling like kind of the way
I put it is I feel like I'm cancer in a
way where I'm like this thing where if
people are around me now people they can
get canceled or and that's probably
ended that was more probably a couple
years ago but it does feel like that you
know like oh I'm I'm this [__] up
thing and if you're near me everybody's
mad at you now so I just kind of seclude
well that's sad
that's that's thoughtful and and uh you
know we appreciate that I think there
are whole kind of vibe is
it is what it is you know I think um
that that the idea of uh there being
negative comments there's going to be
negative comments no matter what you do
um and I I'm personally kind of
interested in uh just the story of you
know
what happens after all that right you
know like um I think uh that a lot of
people in the world would take the
position that cancel culture went too
far and that it's you know enough and
and I think that having really really
taken the brunt of it and uh you know
showing up to to speak up for yourself
after the fact that there's some courage
in that and um anybody who wants to you
know kick you while you're down and and
you know pile on to a bunch of traumatic
stuff like um maybe maybe what we're
doing here is uh an exercise in in
shining a light on that and uh and and
showing it to be unnecessary
yeah I mean thank you for
um
sorry I don't
I promise I'm not like this all the time
no that's okay I mean it's just honestly
it's it's it's it's better that you're
not like you know
right exactly I know hey guys
like I mean this is like what like you
know you're gonna hate me for doing this
but I'm gonna go deep okay
um you brought up the fact that like you
didn't want to come on people's podcasts
because you felt like a cancer
but did you always feel like a cancer
like was that that that's not the first
time that you felt coming on because I
the reason I say that is because you
know you see you
your whole idea of like making videos
would be for shock value right and and I
would think that like
to have that kind of a thought system
you kind of had like a lot of resentment
in you before you started making videos
and you found out like that you know you
can make videos and then you became
shocking and and maybe in your head you
were like like [__] it like [__]
everybody I feel like a cancer anyway in
life so like I'm just gonna go like you
felt justified by going that hard
is that some level of accuracy to it
yeah I mean I think
it sounds weird but I am not like as a
human as a person I'm not
like a gross person I'm not like a
shocking person in my real life I'm not
making crazy gross jokes I'm not I've
never been that I've always been really
quiet so with the videos I mean I grew
up watching you know scary movie and uh
you know Chappelle and all those things
so that was kind of how my
what I liked formed and I love playing
characters and wearing wigs and doing
all these things and I do love getting a
reaction like I would make these videos
and I would show my mom who's like
really religious Christian
and my favorite part of making the
videos would be watching my mom's
reactions because it was so like I love
when people scream because they're
laughing or they scream because they're
shocked it's just like oh my God and so
I was doing that and I did it in high
school like I would do these video
projects in high school and the teachers
would freak out because they were like I
can't believe he did this like what the
[__] and that was kind of you know the
beginning of that so yeah but it was
weird because then in when I'm not in
these videos I'm not that bad at all
people were really liking the videos and
I was you know being asked to go to
YouTube things and I had YouTube friends
and and but there were a few people that
were mad and were calling it out and I
was you know being like no well people
think it's funny and I'm not trying to
be offensive so it's fine which is
stupid I should have listened to those
people but
um but yeah it wasn't like I never
wanted to be that right like I never
want to be the person that's making all
this horrible [__] like that was not
what I wanted to do
I find that um
I I'm feeling a great deal of compassion
for you and uh you know like I I see
like I I can you're honest You're
vulnerable I can feel like the the the
trauma of like everything that's
happened with uh you know cancel culture
and I I kind of like
you know I
like I can just maybe it's like uh you
know empathy but I I can feel your pain
and it makes me
you know
it cultivates compassion you know I want
to like I want everything to be okay for
you
thank you that's the nicest thing ever
I mean sorry that I'm making you feel
bad no no I mean it's not like yeah like
that's yeah you're gonna make me feel
bad but it's like I don't know like
Scott said You know here you've uh you
know like the the fact of you being
nervous it uh I mean I could see the uh
indicators of like picking your fingers
like you're uncomfortable talking about
this [__] clearly you're blowing out
you're like yeah but to Scott's Point
that's real that's vulnerable yeah to
Scott's Point there's like there you
know it's okay if you pick your feet I
know no I'm like oh [__] no I always
notice things like that with people
because I I mean I I'm the same way too
you know I remember uh at you know one
of our our sober functions talking to a
sober guy
and uh and and just expressing to him
that um
that like
I uh
felt really just ashamed of what you
know what I had become like what I
turned into with drugs and alcohol and I
was and I was like yeah like it's
probably not good to be so like shameful
about it and and this guy said no dude
like uh regret is absolutely healthy and
important and the way forward so but
there's certainly you know no no
judgment here you know thank you I mean
no I appreciate it and I want to get
better at like talking about stuff I
think and I've tried to do it on my
podcast but then I always just shut down
because
I don't
I don't know I don't wanna
it's just really complicated it's hard
to talk about cancel stuff cancel
culture when
like I'm not delusional I know why I got
canceled I I understand it I get it I
feel sorry about it
um but yeah it was a lot and it I don't
think any person should be put through
that because if I didn't have
Rylan I'd be dead like so I and I I want
to at some point talk about it more
because I feel I got to talk about the
therapy a lot I'm like I want to do
something for people because
cancel culture isn't just on YouTube
it's everywhere it's in people like I've
had people that I know who have lost
jobs because of a patient who said
something that wasn't true and then this
and that it's like it's happening
everywhere and so many people feel like
it feel like this so it's like yeah at
some point I do want to get better
talking about it because I you know I I
am grateful that I
am okay
after all of that but it's hard to talk
about that because then people are like
oh you're trying to you know [__]
feel bad about or be a victim and this
and that so then I just say well [__]
I'm just not going to talk about
you know yeah I think the worst thing
that you can do though is just to like
um
make a joke you know like uh make a joke
about it or you know at least because
then that's just uh it's a you know
deflection for sure and
um you know I think the more that you're
honest and vulnerable about it the it
always reminds me of this the the word
personality comes from the the root word
Persona which means to wear a mask and I
always like the people that have the
best Personalities in the world just
makes me think of like
that they're covering up the most you
know so if somebody's like hey what's
like they're just two on and they're too
charismatic it's like that person's
really hurt inside
right so you don't I think want to
make a joke about anything you've ever
done because it's not funny and
everybody knows it's not funny so just
be real about it just like [__] dude
you're pretty honest and vulnerable with
us and that's a lot easier than being
like okay so anyway that is so [__]
true because at the beginning when I
started trying to get back into making
stuff again I was really making a lot of
jokes about suicide like too much
borderline like why was I doing that
um and
I in the moment I I try not to do this
but I watched like a video of somebody
reacting to the video because it was my
first one back and you know since I had
been canceled and one of the suicide
jokes came up and the person was just
like um
and I was like oh I just felt so
embarrassed I felt so stupid I was just
like oh that's I'm so it's like it put
me back in high school and I would be
the first one to make the fat joke so
that like people wouldn't you know I'm
like in on the joke he he like I get it
titties like whatever so it put me in
that same space where I'm like oh so now
that's my new thing I'm trying not to
make jokes about how I look and I'm
trying not to make suicide jokes and all
these things because they are real and I
do use humor but yeah there is a certain
point where it makes people feel like oh
this is dark yeah sure it's like yeah
but everybody does it so don't beat
yourself up for it I mean [__] dude you
know I probably made 20 mistakes like
that today but it's like uh I think
being aware of it really makes a
difference to where like if you do do it
don't beat yourself up just like [__]
right I did it and you move on right
instead of vapors they're using flavored
Air instead of electronics we're all
natural over here go to try fume.com
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com slash Stevo and use the
promo code Stevo at checkout you will
not only get a great deal but you'll get
an additional 10 off your order because
you are a listener of the Wild Ride
podcast
yeah dude